[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
when you're a kid I can always be
protective cared for then I can see
Thanks should think is too much hanging
out with us makes you a loser too but
when you're alone as a kid
[Music]
the monster she was weaker
[Applause]
you don't even know they're getting
close there until it's too late
what work important ID nowhere okay well
I'm starting it cheap and pretty sure
this is not my same bathroom as your
mother sometimes yes then you probably
have crap that's still not funny don't
you guys coming in ah
greywater what the hell is great one
basically piss and [ __ ] home is telling
you we have to splash around millions of
gallons of dairy pee wait are you
seriously doesn't smell like a cop
donation you have you ever heard of a
staffing factoring all sorts of definite
less so unsanitary you're ruling Salewa
are coming inside of a toilet bowl right
now here the reason why we're in this
position my gosh sneaker is it spread
eruptions what if she's still here
[Music]
[Applause]
you
you